Двійко українських винищувачів МіГ-29 на малій висоті виконують бойовий політ з повним боєкомплектом.
За штурвалом пілот із позивним "Джус". Він - один з тих, кого називають "Привидами Києва".
Попри кількісну і якісну перевагу російської авіації,
українські льотчики з перших днів повномасштабної війни тримають контроль над небом.
Наш особовий склад - як льотний, так і наземний -
адаптувався до умов цієї війни і витискають з цієї техніки не 100 відсотків,
а, мабуть, 300 відсотків того, чого з неї можна витиснути.
Як у тактичному плані, так і в технічному. Оскільки деякі літаки просто
цілодобово літають з такою високою інтенсивністю,
відповідно це впливає і на їхнє технічне обслуговування,
тобто люди цілодобово працюють на цих літаках.
Винищувачі МіГ-29 і Су-27 є основними бойовими літаками українських Повітряних сил.
Також застосовуються штурмовики Су-25 і бомбардувальники Су-24.
МіГ-29, на яких літає зокрема і "Джус", у середньому 1989-91 років виробництва.
Такі машини виконують бойові завдання, але часто за межами своїх технічних можливостей.
Наприклад, ті самі "шахеди". Наш бортовий радар,
створений 40 років тому, не був розрахований на цілі такого розміру і таких швидкостей.
І коли наші льотчики все ж вишукують і знаходять ці "шахеди",
і все ж таки успішно вражають - це вже є таким тактичним дивом,
оскільки сказати гарантовано, що це заводом закладено,
ти маєш зробити по інструкції і все вийде - на жаль, так воно не працює.
За роки незалежності в Україні не з'явилося жодного нового літака.
З 2014 року стан авіації покращився завдяки модернізації,
а пілоти отримали більше досвіду.
Утім, українські льотчики досі працюють на радянській техніці.
А спадок СРСР був чималий. У Музеї важкої бомбардувальної авіації в Полтаві
його можна побачити на власні очі.
За різними підрахунками і тільки з відкритих джерел, бо складно точно встановити кількість,
але безумовно ця кількість була більш ніж одна тисяча бойових літаків.
Ще плюс 500 додайте гелікоптерів різного призначення.
Україна тоді, зважаючи на її невелику територію - 1600 км із заходу на схід,
мала достатньо величезний авіапотенціал.
За часів Радянського Союзу саме в Україні базувалася стратегічна авіація.
Тому на момент розпаду СРСР Україна поступалася за кількістю
і потенціалом стратегічної авіації лише Сполученим Штатам
і могла на рівних змагатися з Росією і Китаєм.
Нині такі літаки можна побачити хіба що в музеї.
Далекосяжні Ту-22М3, Ту-95МС - носії крилатих і ядерних ракет.
В Україні це - унікальні музейні експонати, а в Росії - зброя.
Саме з Ту-22 РФ запускає ракети Х-22.
Такі ракети поцілили по житловому будинку в Дніпрі у січні цьогоріч і по торговому центрі в Кременчуці влітку.
Надзвуковий Ту-160 із розмахом крил 55 метрів теж викликає неоднозначні відчуття.
Колись він вважався найбільшим і найпотужнішим бомбардувальником планети,
а від пілотів отримав прізвисько "Білий лебідь".
В Україні один з чотирьох полків нашої дивізії - 13-ої важкої дивізії в Прилуках,
там було 19 літаків таких зосереджено. Це за відкритими джерелами.
І саме в Прилуках вони і тестувалися: виходили в надзвуковий режим,
запускали крилаті ракети і таке інше.
На жаль, цей літак на сьогодні досі приносить смерть,
запускаючи ракети по українським містам.
Незалежна Україна проголосила себе мирною і без'ядерною державою.
Тож, наприклад, із 19-ти Ту-160-х, які базувалися в незалежній Україні,
десять - розпиляли на металобрухт.
Ще вісім - передали Росії замість боргів за газ.
Один - у 2000 році власним ходом перелетів з Прилук до Полтави "на вічну стоянку".
Ту-95 було утилізовано, точно не скажу,
але три таких літаки було передано РФ знову.
Вони були носіями крилатих ракет, отже, їм також були передані і 575 крилатих ракет серії Х-55,
які вони можуть нести на такому спеціальному барабані револьверного типу.
Чи була можливість в України зберегти стратегічні ракетоносці-бомбардувальники?
Чи знадобилися б вони нині? Співробітник музею Віктор Мирошник,
хоч і віддає належне творінню радянських конструкторів, у цьому не певен.
Ці літаки стратегічні бомбардувальники вони збиралися і збираються на Казанському авіаційному заводі.
І, як ми знаємо з відкритих джерел, це відомо, в Радянському Союзі
на території України не було важливих стратегічних заводів,
які б виробляли ці стратегічні бомбардувальники.
Усе це було на території Російської Федерації.
Тому виникає питання, чи могли б ми їх підтримувати в бойовому стані?
Це ж не машина, не автомобіль.
Пілот "Джус" так само говорить, що значні видатки на утримання стратегічної авіації
і підготовку льотчиків були б не виправданими.
Як би ми їх застосували? Так само, як і вони, виконували б пуски ракет Х-22?
Так само влучаючи куди попало? Так само тероризуючи їхні міста?
Наскільки легше стало би бійцям десь під Бахмутом?
Ні на скільки. Бо все одно лишається величезна перевага
в артилерії, величезна перевага в тактичній, армійській авіації,
в танках, у бойових машинах піхоти.
На думку льотчика, протягом останніх 20 років Україні варто було б зосередитися
на модернізації тактичної авіації - тих самих МіГ-29.
Утім, нині, каже "Джус", це вже робити запізно,
адже озброєння радянських літаків уже не відповідає вимогам сучасної війни, а запчастин - мало.
На деякі типи літаків у Європі і в західних країнах немає запчастин в принципі,
оскільки вони їх не використовували і вони в них на озброєнні не стояли.
І в певний момент ці запчастини закінчуються.
Плюс питання наявності авіаційного озброєння саме під ці літаки.
Так, зараз воно поки що є, але воно витрачається щодня, і ці запаси поповнити немає звідки.
Деяких типів озброєння більше немає ніде. Звісно, крім нашого ворога.
Наразі західна платформа, західні літаки - це єдиний шлях виправлення
тих наших помилок минулого, історичних помилок,
через які ми недостатньо були підготовлені в авіаційному плані до цієї війни.
І ці помилки були викликані не тим, що хтось не хотів,
а знову ж таки глобальним станом економіки держави і ще багатьма факторами.
Зокрема і впливом самої ж Росії.
Американські багатоцільові винищувачі F-16 в українських повітряних силах
називають оптимальною платформою. За словами пілота "Джуса",
ці літаки зможуть кардинально змінити хід бойових дій.
А також допоможуть остаточно залишити радянський спадок для музеїв.